>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Mark Dimunation: Short
and sweet this afternoon.
We are going to begin
landing on Earth.
We have three very
promising talks ahead of us.
Leslie Overstreet,
who's the Curator
of Natural History Rare Books
at the Smithsonian Libraries
will introduce our next speaker.
Leslie.
[ Applause ]
>> Leslie Overstreet:
Thanks, Mark.
Actually, before I
introduce our next speaker,
I've been very fortuitously
reminded of something
that might be of interest
to a number of you,
and Mark has given me permission
to make a very brief
announcement.
The Guild of Natural
Science Illustrators,
which was founded 50 years ago
this year at the National Museum
of Natural History
just down the street,
is celebrating its anniversary
with its annual conference
this year here in Washington.
It will be July 15 through 21,
primarily at American
University,
but with at least one day at
the Natural History Museum.
You can get more information
from brochures at the back.
There's a representative from
the Guild here who's happy
to answer questions, and you can
consult their website, GNSI.org.
So now I am very happy
to introduce Kay Etheridge
as our next speaker.
With a Doctorate in Zoology
from the University of Florida,
Kay is a Professor of Biology
at Gettysburg College
in Pennsylvania.
She teaches courses in Biology,
Comparative Physiology,
and Ecology.
Her research and publications
have ranged from hibernation
in lizards, estivation
in salamanders,
and the foraging behavior
of tropical bat species.
Beginning at least 10 years
ago, probably a bit longer,
with her publication
of Loathsome Beasts,
Images of Reptiles and
Amphibians in Art and Science ,
she has been a strong
proponent of the expansion
of STEM education to STEAM,
incorporating the arts
with the sciences.
[ Laughter and Applause ]
Her focus on the role of
images in plants and animals
in the history of the
natural sciences led
to her being a driving force
in organizing and speaking
at the International Conference
on the 17th century naturalist
and artist, Maria Sibylla
Merian at the University
of Amsterdam last summer which
I was lucky enough to attend.
Her talk today will be just
as interesting I'm sure --
Art and Science Intertwined.
Please join me in welcoming
Professor Kay Etheridge.
[ Applause ]
>> Kay Etheridge: Thank
you, Leslie, and thank you
to the organizers of this event.
It's just something I'm
really enjoying very much.
So to get started here I've
already changed my talk
with notes from this morning,
so we'll see how this works in.
But some points were made that
I'd like to link to my own talk
because it's thoughts I've had,
and I think they'll
link very nicely now
that we're back on Earth.
So I'm going to start
talking about nature images
with this very sophisticated
one.
This is going to be -- this
is going to be Biology.
I'll just say there's
obviously many kinds
of nature, but this is Biology.
So I'm going to make
the argument --
I'm going to talk about the
purposes of these nature images,
meaning Biology images.
What purposes can
they serve aside
from being aesthetically
beautiful
and stimulating and inspiring?
You can -- they can
be decorative,
they can be symbolic,
they certainly can be used
to influence, you know,
don't smoke in the forest
and drop your cigarettes.
And I'm going to concentrate
on the information in images
because as a biologist that's
one way I look at images,
is what information is there?
And how is this information
presented?
And since I was a child
I liked creepy crawlers,
hence the snakes
and bats and such.
And I'll get back
to this image later.
But there's a tremendous amount
of information packed
into this image.
There's also the perspective
of the viewer which we heard
about this morning to
take into consideration.
And here you have your
face-up close in a slice
of tropical life in
what's going on here.
So a little bit about how nature
images have changed over time.
And I'm going to zip through
many millennia very quickly
on that.
And then slow down as we
get to the Renaissance.
And how have these
images been spread?
How have they been disseminated?
There's a couple
of different way.
We'll talk about that.
And the last thing, and the
most important in a way,
is why are these portrayals
of nature important?
And the biggest point
I want to make is
that they affect how we
understand and how we think
about the natural world.
And I think there was
some of this also brought
into the talks this morning,
but we're just looking at it
on a different level now.
So, I'm going to
use a case study
on my favorite naturalist
artist, Maria Sibylla Merian,
and that's too immersed in now
because I'm writing
a book on her.
And so there will be
a lot of her images.
And this is one of
her images as well.
So we're going to go
back 20,000 years.
No, more than that,
because this is B.C., right?
So nature images have
been around a long time,
longer than this even.
So, clearly they're important.
You don't go into a cave
with a torch, with materials
that you've made yourself,
and pigments that you've dug
up from the Earth, and somehow
go up high and make these images
of these animals unless
it's important to you.
Why this was important
enough to do, I don't know.
This is not something I work on.
But it's early nature images.
Moving forward many millennia,
you've got frescoes in Greece.
And these are somewhat
naturalistic.
You can tell there
are dolphin and fish.
I don't know what the
purposes of these were.
They may have been symbolic.
But they're also showing
what was around them.
There's water all
around and there's fish.
And the fish are important
to their livelihood.
So these images continue.
This is a fairly
naturalistic lion except
for the problem that, if that's
an adult male he would be taller
than that man on his hind legs.
So here symbolism is important.
This is a king, and the king
can't be smaller than the lion.
The king can't look afraid
in front of the lion.
So even though you've
got a naturalistic image,
it's not about the lion.
It's not about what a lion
looks like or what a lion does.
It's about the king's power.
So this is maybe decorative.
I don't know.
I took this photograph
in the museum in Naples,
but this would have been
on the floor in Pompei.
And it's in pretty good
shape because it was buried
for a long time by Vesuvius.
And then they excavated it and
looked at these mosaics closely.
Each little piece is about
the size of maybe one
of your fingernails,
and they portray fairly
naturalistic organisms.
You can easily tell that's
a squid and a dogfish
and an ichthyologist could
probably identify a lot
of these fish to species.
There's enough information there
to tell you what kind
of fish this was.
Nature images continue on in the
medieval times in many forms.
And in some ways, less
naturalistic than things
that proceeded them in Europe.
And I just put up three
kinds of books, nature books.
These wouldn't have been
printed books, but handwritten
and hand-illustrated
before the printing press.
And I always -- when I show
this, I ask my students
if they know what kind of
plant that is in that herbal.
These were used for medical.
>> Mandrake, mandrake.
>> Kay Etheridge: Right.
And what do you think --
if I say Harry Potter,
how fast do you think
they'd get that?
Yeah. So, this mandrake.
They look at the Greek and
Latin, and they don't make --
get Mandrake out of it.
But they've read Harry
Potter or seen the movies.
So herbals conveyed information.
And the idea would be to -- if
it was an illustrated herbal,
would be to give you
enough information
that you would choose the
right plant for a medicine.
And some of the herbals --
it's pretty hard to
tell what the plant is.
Bestiaries are another
thing altogether.
Bestiaries would
have varying degrees
of naturalistic representation
of animals,
but that wasn't the point.
The point was to make
-- to tell the stories,
to have an allegory, to
have a moral, often related
to the Bible, although a lot
of these stories were
much older than the Bible.
This is a gorgeous example
that's in the University
of Aberdeen, and it's online.
You could see images
through the whole thing.
So this is about 1200.
And what is that animal?
I can't see that.
The slide is blinding.
What is that animal?
There's lots of them.
What are those?
>> Mark Dimunation:
They're snakes.
>> Kay Etheridge:
They're snakes, right?
>> Yes.
>> Kay Etheridge: Okay.
Snakes arrive coming
out of the fire.
These are salamanders.
So they look nothing like what
we think of as the salamander.
But the Latin text with
this says salamander.
And the salamanders are
poisoning the apples
and poisoning the water.
So there's information here.
Salamanders are poisonous
and they survive fire.
There's not very
good information
about what a salamander
looks like, but the monk
who illustrated this probably
didn't know what a salamander
was or what it looked like.
So hold that image and hold
the idea of fire and poison
and salamanders, and
we'll come back to that.
Okay. So in hunting [inaudible].
These are beautiful.
They're decorative.
But there's information
about how
to find things you want to hunt.
So these kinds of images
through the medieval period.
And then, if I can
go forward here,
in the Renaissance
the rebirth --
there is a move towards
more naturalism.
And Leonardo de Vinci's sort
of the post child for that,
and Albrecht Durer's
another one.
And this is the Little
Tuft of Grass of Piece
of Turf I think is the title.
And it's about -- I'd
say it's about that big.
It's a tiny painting.
I've only see it once in person.
And it's got beautifully
rendered --
see the dandelion here?
You can tell exactly
what that is.
And then he did animals
and this bunny.
You feel like you could touch
his fur, and it would be soft.
And this is what he thought
a rhinoceros looked like.
So this is not Durer's fault.
If he had even seen a rhinoceros
it would probably be a more
naturalistic rendering.
But he did not see one.
At least we don't think he did.
And he based this
incredibly long-living image
of a rhinoceros on
notes from someone else,
maybe sketches from
someone else.
I don't actually
recall the whole story.
But this image gets
reprinted all the way
up into 19th century German
textbooks as being a rhinoceros.
So this dissemination of
images changes dramatically
with the advent of
the printing press.
It then becomes easy to make
images very quickly relative
to hand-copying each one.
It also makes them
less expensive.
They're still expensive
to the average person,
but they're much less expensive
than if they're hand-made
images.
So images are spreading faster.
They're not always
spreading accurate
or naturalistic information, but
they're moving around faster.
So here's 16th century herbal
on the right, a page from one.
And I wanted to also bring
out the point about color.
So some of the information in
images is color, and Leslie
and I were just talking
about this at lunch.
We were talking about this
at lunch because later
on naturalists actually
used guides
as to how to describe color.
But if you bought a
book in these days,
you usually bought it, or print,
you usually bought it uncolored.
To buy a colored copy
would cost much, much more.
And so people would
color them themselves.
So the books you see now in the
Library, in Leslie's library,
that are colored, changes
are pretty good they were not
colored by the person who
actually produced the book.
But they were colored later.
And that -- the quality of
coloring, the way it's put on,
whether the colors are natural
or not, varies tremendously.
So colored printing is not
coming along for hundreds --
for a long time after my talk.
So everything you see
will be hand-colored.
All right.
So in terms of dissemination
of both information and images,
at the same time you've got the
printing press revolutionizing
how images are made.
You've got people,
Europeans, travelling the globe
and collecting things.
Now if you think that
all of the animals
on the planet are what you've
read about in the Bible or seen
in a bestiary, you're
going to be surprised
when you see an armadillo or
a giraffe or a hippopotamus
or a crocodile in these things
that start coming back
all over the world.
You're going to see a banana.
Imagine a banana.
And this stuff is coming back
and people are collecting it,
and collecting is even quite
a competitive sport among the
people who can afford it.
So people make collection
cabinets,
and a cabinet can be anything
literally from a small cabinet
to a suite of rooms if you --
or prints, and can afford it.
And this one is one of
my favorites in part just
because it does name
Old Worm, Ole Worm.
But he was a Danish Physician,
and this is from a book he had
published about his cabinet.
So they'd make the collection
and they'd publish about it,
so you've got images
of the collection.
And you can't see it very well,
but mixed in with baby stuffed
polar bears and naturalia,
or excuse me, artifacts
from humans like kayaks,
are little art objects,
like there's a little
Giambologna statuette
over there.
And he also had animals, alive.
This is the only known image
made from life of a Great Auk.
They've been extinct
for quite a while.
This was his pet.
And I guess he probably
stuffed it when it died.
But he illustrated it.
He had it illustrated .
As far as I know he did not
make his own illustrations.
So these images -- then
people can see what an auk is
and they can name it
and they can think
about its place in
the natural world.
So this brings us
to other travelers.
I like this guy, Pierre Belon.
He would include
like fish recipes
in his book on great stuff.
He was French after all.
But here's this giraffe.
I believe he made his
own images in woodcuts.
And here's this chameleon.
This chameleon's going to
pop up again later, too.
And he travelled extensively.
I'm just putting in
here, as an example.
And people who travelled
brought things back.
And other people
collected these things.
And this was a collection in
Naples made by an apothecary,
Ferrante, Imperato, and it was
visited by people from all over.
So a part of the grand
tour of a young gentleman
or scholar would be to go and
visit these collection cabinets.
And then these people made
images of their collections.
They published these in books.
There's a whole book
of his collection.
They brought their little dogs.
But what I want to
focus in on is
in these collections there
are also books and prints.
So the collection is
artifacts and objects,
books and prints as well.
And I've been really lucky
twice to teach a course
at Gettysburg College
to undergraduates
where the students made
a collection cabinet
in the art gallery.
And this was in 2012.
I team-taught it with
Felicia Else, my colleague
in Renaissance Art History.
And the students assembled this,
and these are facsimilie books.
I don't want you
librarians to worry
that we have actual Aldrovandi's
line out for everyone to fondle.
And then this was the one
last fall, and narwhal tusk.
This is to show we have Catesby
prints and then we have a gar
to go with Catesby's gar.
This was the students' idea to
put these pairings together.
And we've got the crocodile
and the alligator skulls.
So the point is these
collections --
it was just as important for
them to have images as it was
for them to have the artifacts.
And then if you visited
a collection,
you might make an image and then
share that with your friends.
Or you might document
your collection
by publishing a book on it.
So the physical object,
the artifact,
and the images were
very much interwoven.
So here's a painting to
Jacopo Ligozzi who worked
for the Medici and was sort of
loaned out by them, I think,
to Aldrovandi when he
made his encyclopedia.
Now I want you just to
compare the information
in these two things.
I scaled it as nearly as I could
to make the bird's
head the same size,
so let me just flip it back.
That's actually better.
What's the difference
in the information?
>> The color.
>> Kay Etheridge:
The color's huge.
Yeah, the color is enormous.
But also, once you
start trying --
if you scale it to
the bird's head,
you notice the tail's not long
enough in the finished plates.
So sometimes you run out
of space on our plate
or you woodblock or your page,
even if it's a folio size.
Sometimes you just run out.
So there's more information
in the color.
But if you want to print it
and sell it to a lot of people,
obviously you can't hand-copy
this at any cost-effective rate.
So the printing -- you
lose some information,
but you also can
disseminate it more widely.
Okay. So here's a famous
animal encyclopedia by a Swiss,
Conrad Gesner, and who's
our star over here.
Well, we've seen him before.
That's Belon's [inaudible].
It's oriented differently.
He credits Belon for this.
So this information that was
collected is now in an image
that more people can see
in this encyclopedia.
And guess who's also back
in this encyclopedia?
Yeah. So sometimes you
can tell -- notice the --
isn't he facing the
opposite direction there?
Yeah. So when you
copy something,
and then it's printed, it flips.
So you can sort of watch these
things flip back and forth
which is fun, and it's not
identical to [inaudible] print,
but it's pretty close.
There's actually a
mistake in the toe position
of the chameleon in this one,
but only a herpetologist
like me would notice.
So Gesner did something
really interesting.
He did not just compile
other people's information.
He look at mythical salamanders.
Now this is our salamanders,
not snake-like,
but it's hairy, which is weird.
And then he had his artists
draw a European fire salamander,
they're called fire
salamanders, from a specimen.
And just for fun, there's
what they look like.
Little snub-nosed
things, color pattern.
And if you look up close at
those dots on the back --
-- those are poison glands.
So the beast theory
wasn't entirely wrong.
You wouldn't kill an adult human
with the poison from these,
but this protects them
against predators.
They are poisonous.
So what's the story with
them surviving fire?
Well, they hibernate in rotting
logs and under the bark of logs.
So the peasant brings the wood
in, throws it on the fire.
Salamander thaws out and
does I am out of here.
Goes, you know, running
out of the fire.
And they think, oh, they
sprang from the fire.
So there's -- some of these
stories and myths have more
to them than you might imagine.
So, jumping forward
another hundred years.
This is our protagonist.
Pretty pearl earrings and
very lady-like, but she ends
up at some point going
through the jungle of Suriname
in South America and making
pictures of bird-eating spiders.
So she was quite intrepid.
But more than that, she
studied the life cycles of moths
and butterflies on
the post plants
of the moths and butterflies.
And this is where I
want to make the point
that she changed how
we viewed nature.
She put plants and animals
together before anybody did
in a way that was
ecologically relevant,
not just to be decorative,
but that species
does eat that plant.
So that's the story I
want to focus on now.
So she was born into a
publishing and printing family.
I'll come back to
them in a minute.
But her father died when
she was about three,
and her mother remarried
this guy, Jacob Marrel,
who was a very good still-life
painter and included insects.
There's a butterfly
up there somewhere.
But he also did portraits
of tulips
for people who collected tulips.
And he decorated these
with little insects.
And as far as I can tell,
he's the only tulip painter
who made these tulip
portraits that put in insects
and he shows them
eating the plant leaves.
Most people wanted
their tulip portraits
to be perfect, not damaged.
And he trained her.
And I think she was
very influenced by him.
But the family firm --
these are her stepbrothers.
And they published this
encyclopedia of insects.
And the interest thing about
this is she would have grown
up with this stuff in
the house probably.
This is a plate that's many,
many pages before this plate,
so the adults are here.
Many, many pages later
are the caterpillars.
And there's no association
made between them
and there's no food plants.
It's just specimens on a page.
And they're categorizing them
by whether the caterpillars
are furry or not furry.
So they're trying to
understand all of this nature,
but they're not putting
it in any natural context.
They're not putting it
in an ecological context.
And that's where
Merian comes along.
She had one person before her
who looked at the life cycles
of these, and put the
caterpillars and adults together
and the pupae, and this
was Johannes Goedaert,
a Dutchman who published
his book a little more
than a decade before
she published hers.
And she read it.
She knew his work.
But notice, no plants.
And sometimes not even
the full lifecycle.
He wasn't as successful as she
was at raising them all the way
through the lifecycle.
But still good work,
very good work.
She comes along and at the age
of 32 publishes what she calls
her first caterpillar book,
Raupen , German
for caterpillar.
And that's the frontispiece.
And she publishes two more
in her lifetime plus
a third tropical book
which we'll get to.
She studied insects for --
we know she started when she
was 13, she wrote it herself,
and probably until
she died at 70.
So for more than five
decades she studied insects.
More than 300 species
of insects.
But she's best know
today for being an artist
because she produced these
beautiful compositions.
So here we've got
one that's colored,
and here we've got
the etching engraving.
She was taught to make
prints, so in her books,
all of these books, she did --
she raised all of the insects,
she painted them, she engraved
the plates and/or etched.
I need to talk to some
expert about that.
And she wrote the text
and she marketed them.
She had a lot of control
over the process which led
to interesting output.
So just to show you in terms of
information, here is Goedaert
and the same species by Merian.
So that caterpillar
eats that plant.
And she has not only the
pupae, but she has the eggs.
And Goedaert's still talking
about spontaneous generation
of insects in his book.
He says, they're born
on the wind in one case.
He talks about eggs sometimes,
so he's not even
internally consistent.
But he didn't quite believe
that all of them came from eggs.
And she did.
She studied it very explicitly.
Then if you color the images
you add a lot of information.
And you add dramatic impact.
So if you have a wealthy buyer
and you can sell a colored
copy, more power to you.
Now this is the same species.
Look at his caterpillar
up there, her caterpillar,
and this is the actual
caterpillar.
Now it's hard when
you're rendering this
to show those long thin
light-color bristles.
That's really hard to convey,
so the bristles look shorter.
But other than that
it's very identifiable.
Okay. So how to you
make an image like this?
Well, first you have
to find the animal.
So where is it?
Different species --
where's the caterpillar?
[ Inaudible Speakers ]
You guys have a good eye.
Oop, my thing got moved.
It's a little to the left
of the circle [laughter].
I went to the 16-9 format
and didn't adjust for that.
So, anyway.
But you can see the caterpillar.
So you've got to go
and find these things.
And she'd go out in the
gardens and she'd collect them.
And this is the best
stage to start.
Finding eggs is next
to impossible.
Catching the adults -- forget
about it because then you got
to get them to mate
and lay the eggs.
So you start with
the caterpillar.
Then you bring it back.
And she used wooden boxes,
but you've got to raise it.
I've looked at papers
where professionals raising
this species only got 25%
to metamorphose to adults.
And they were working
on one species
and they had graduate
students and undergraduates
in a climate-controlled lab.
It's not easy to do.
Some months she would
have been having
to raise 10 different
species at the same time.
She also -- the year
she published this book,
she had a one-year-old daughter
and an eight-year-old daughter.
And not a lot of domestic help.
So makes me tired just
thinking about it.
She said that she had to feed
these caterpillars every day.
They all had to have
specific foods.
And she wrote in her book that,
I could hardly give
them enough nettles
so active were they
in their feeding.
These things eat more than
their bodyweight a day
in plant material.
I don't know what you weight,
but for me that would
be a lot of salad.
So this is a lot of work.
And then she has to
stay up and draw them.
She would sometimes stay up all
night to get this changing stage
so that she could illustrate
it and, of course, know nothing
but candles and I
guess little oil lamps.
And she would show the whole
lifecycle on the plant.
This animal does
indeed eat fennel.
So how did she make
these images?
What's the process.
So she -- we have
her study images.
They're actually in Russia.
Long story.
But we don't have
the plant images.
They've been lost.
We don't know how.
So this is the lifecycle
including some parasites
of this particular species.
This is a -- she
would do a painting,
and then she would make
the engraved plate.
And I have these
oriented the same.
No, these are reversed.
And then she might
paint the plate
or she might sell it unpainted.
So you can see the
information transfer.
The thing that's
missing, of course,
is the original image
of the plant.
And the study doesn't
have as many insects.
She's added -- by the time she
published it, she's decided
to add another size
of caterpillar
that she didn't have originally,
and she's added another type
of parasite in the eggs.
So a lot of information.
Now, I just want to put --
hold up, back up there quickly
so you can compare the
information in his.
Same species.
All right.
So, don't want to
run out of time here.
She's -- in her first
book she had 50 plates;
her second book she had 50
plates and she had the text.
And the text is amazing.
It's outside the scope of
this study of this talk today,
but she looked at behavior, she
looked at the effect of climate,
she looked at all sorts of
things about the insects.
But she was a curious woman.
And when she was living in
Amsterdam later in life,
she saw collections
of tropical insects
like these morpho
butterflies -- spectacular.
There are no European insects
that come close in
size or color.
And she said, I want
to go see those.
And I want to learn --
she said, I don't want
to just see the dead specimens.
I want to learn how they live,
how they grow, what came before.
So at age 52 she and one
of her grown daughters take
a two-months ship voyage
to Suriname, Dutch Suriname.
She stays on various
sugar plantations and goes
out into the jungle
and the details
of making this book
are another whole talk.
But she's there two
years and she comes back.
She makes a fabulous book.
Now, to put it into
context, other people went
to the New World before her.
This is the kind of
images was in the book.
This is a woodblock print
so it's surrounded by text.
Hans Sloane, whose collection
founded the British Museum,
was also in Jamaica before her.
He was in Jamaica here.
He didn't publish his
book until after her book,
but he made images --
animals on one page,
plants on another page,
never the two shall meet.
And this is what
Merian produced.
Now, in terms of size, this is a
full folio sheet, so it's large.
If you bought the colored
edition, and it's large,
and it's this dramatic,
this is like 3D color IMAX
to the average European
person who's been looking
at things uncolored,
smaller, and no drama,
no plants and animals together.
So she made this book and
this is what made her famous.
So I scaled these.
I don't think I corrected
the size exactly right,
but on the left is
the European plates.
They're quarto.
And then the folio is
on the right shown
more or less to scale.
Figs, pomegranates,
bananas, pineapple --
she tried to emphasize a lot
of the exotic plants
that you could eat.
But let's move on.
So what do you do
with this information?
You can do a couple of things.
You can use it to
classify the world.
Linnaeus famously
said something like,
God creates; Linnaeus
classifies.
I'm paraphrasing, but
he was not a modest man.
And he published his
Systema Naturae in 1735,
and the binomial system we use
now is put firmly into place.
But he named a lot of things
based on other people's images.
Not always did they
have a specimen.
They often had images.
And if you're trying to
catalog the natural world,
and understand it, you need
to know what's out there.
And Merian, among many other
artists and naturalists work fed
into the -- were
grist for the mill
of Linnaeus and his followers.
And they named over 200
species of plants and animals
and insects just
from Merian alone.
And that's one of her --
so that's one way you can use
the information in these images.
But I argue that -- that was
only a minor contribution
by Merian.
I think she changed how we
portray the natural world
because after her,
people like Eleazar Albin
and many others started putting
animals and plants together
in ways that were
ecologically relevant.
So here's one example.
Here's another.
George Edwards --
and you can see here,
this lizard is contemplating
eating this butterfly.
It's harder to see.
There's a tiny little ant
there in front of this lizard.
This lizard's name is
actually named after Merian
in the scientific name.
Here is Mark Catesby who came
along afterwards, and his format
of his book is very
similar to Merian's.
And here's a butterfly
and a plant.
But Catesby was fantastic
with birds.
And so here's an
ivory-billed woodpecker.
We wouldn't even really know
what these looked like an aux
if we didn't have these
naturalist artists
because these are
gone, they're extinct.
So to remind you again,
let's get reference.
There's Hans Sloane's boa.
Somebody engraved that for him.
He didn't do the artwork.
There's Merian's little boa.
Now I want to talk about scale.
The talk this morning
made me think --
it reminded me to
talk about scale.
Merian, every image
she made of an insect,
the insect is life-sized.
So when you're looking
at her book, not here,
when you're looking at her
book, you could put that species
of insect up to it, and that's
how big the adult would be.
The caterpillars
grow, obviously.
But the adults -- and I have
a friend who's an artist who's
actually done this, so we know.
So that sphinx moth on
the page is the size
of an adult sphinx
moth would be.
The plants -- sometimes
she couldn't get them
to scale right, and that
boa -- the scale is wrong.
They were not her stars.
Her stars were the insects.
So you wouldn't see
a boa that much --
that size next to a caterpillar,
but at least not an adult one.
So she messed about with the
scale to get it onto a plate.
But she's trying to convey
a lot of information --
the lifecycle of the
insect, the snake,
a lot of information
in one play.
And here's Mark Catesby artfully
draping his little bead snake
because he'd seen Merian's work
and he thought, that's great.
It's a great way to go.
And his pages were
the same size.
They were large.
And he hand-colored
his first editions,
or at least most
of them I'd say.
Now, drama and spectacle, that
came out this morning, too.
So what is more dramatic
than a caiman tossing an
egg-eating snake that's trying
to eat its egg while
also protecting a little
hatching caiman?
This is maternal care
in a crocodilian.
They're one of the few reptiles
that actually do defend their
young, and she's documented this
in quite a dramatic
and baroque way.
But these things to
happen in nature.
So the drama I think
is just as important.
So you've got the ecological
composition with animals
and plants that occur together.
But then you've got drama.
You're drawing in your viewer.
Your viewer is seeing
this tree frog
as eyeing the spider for lunch.
It's seeing this nasty
looking viper rearing
up in a most improbably
anatomical way,
about to go after this
poor little salamander.
And then you've got drama.
So this is my favorite plate
in Merian's Suriname volume.
You've got three
species of spider.
You've got army ants.
You've got leaf cutter ants.
You've got a roach.
You've got a dying
hummingbird and its eggs.
And you've got a guava tree,
which she says the leaf cutter
ants can defoliate overnight
down to something like a
broom handle, and they can.
I've been in Costa Rica
and seen it happen.
She shows the army ants
attacking this roach.
She shows this spider snacking
on an ant while multitasking
and guard its egg sac.
And this bridge of army ant
bodies which actually happens.
This is a screenshot of --
from YouTube of army ants
making a body with their --
a bridge with their bodies.
So there's a lot going
on in this image.
A lot of drama, a
lot of ecology,
a lot of food chains,
a lot of action.
Her images, like others',
other people's images,
get appropriated and
end u in catalogs or --
excuse me, this is a
children's encyclopedia.
This is what you and your
kids look in at night.
This is -- yeah, this is one --
actually this series was owned
by Darwin, so you've got spiders
eating birds copied from that.
This is 170 years
after Merian published
and it's still going on.
And now the mate's
coming in to defend it.
And all of this leads us to
people like John James Audubon.
And so today you could turn
on the Discovery Channel
or Animal Planet ,
or you can look at an
Audubon print, and, of course,
things are interacting
and, of course,
there are these interactions.
But Merian was the first.
I'm not saying somebody else
wouldn't have come along
and done it, but she was
the first to put these kinds
of things into her images.
And that's all.
I want to thank a lot of people
though, especially people
like Leslie and their libraries.
Oh, my goodness, I
couldn't do it without them.
And some funding.
And that's all I have to say.
[ Applause ]
>> Nicki Saylor: Hello.
I'm Nicki Saylor.
I'm Head of the Archive at the
American Folklife Center here
at the Library of Congress.
It is my sincere pleasure
to introduce Tom Keegan.
He's the Director of
Digital Scholarship
and Publishing Studio at the
University of Iowa Libraries.
Tom is in charge of a team of
11 who collaborate with faculty
and students on designing,
creating, circulating,
and archiving this
digital scholarship.
This involves not only
overseeing the University's
Digital Library,
Institutional Repository,
and the Crowdsourcing
Platform DIY History.
Tom and his team
are heavily involved
in helping instructors
thread digital scholarship
into University and
community curricula.
In fact, Tom has long
applied digital methods
in his own teaching
in the Departments
of Rhetoric and English.
So, as a folklore's
archivist I'm delighted
that his talk is titled
"Strong in Their Lowliness --
Everyday People,
Everyday Illustration."
It focuses on how everyday
people, students, soldiers,
[inaudible] artists create
illustrations as a way
to explore their
place in the world.
Tom has a PhD in English
Literature from the University
of Iowa and he did his
dissertation on Pubs
in James Joyce's
Work [laughter].
And as I understand it,
Tom resituated Irish pubs,
a "token symbol of paternalistic
Irish drunkenness" --
this is in quotes -- as the
site for Joyce's development
of a philosophy of being.
And so, read this way, pubs
illustrate ways humans come
to understand their place in
the world through objects,
practices, and later as
part of a public entity.
So, yes, Tom and I
have a shared affinity
for traditional culture,
and how people make meaning
of their lives, how
they express themselves,
and how they situate
themselves within a community.
He and I also have
Iowa in common.
He occupies the job that
I left before arriving
at the Library five years ago.
So I've watched with
pride and admiration
as Tom has taken the Digital
Scholarship Program there
to new heights.
He's absorbed the Campus
Digital Humanities Studio,
doubling the size of the staff.
He's developed the DIY
History Crowdsourcing Platform
into this awesome
publishing gate --
public engagement
tool that boasts more
than 80,000 pages transcribed.
And he provides Digital
Humanities teaching and support
for more than 70 faculty
and their students.
So Tom possesses a rare mix
of confidence, curiosity,
intellectual heft, and seemingly
boundless interpersonal finesse
that helped make --
I heard a laugh --
that helped make program
growth like that possible.
So in preparing for
the introduction,
of course I went Googling,
and I came across his Rate
my Professor site, his entry.
And this is a site
where people can --
students can comment
on their experiences
with a professor and/or course.
And so for the record he
has earned above a 4.0,
above a 4.0, and a chili pepper.
One of the comments seemed
particularly suitable to point
up to what we're about
to experience today.
A student wrote that
Tom is a, quote,
"awesome guy to listen to.
Love his rants,"
unquote [laughter].
As an aside, rants were
mentioned in multiple entries
and I've been witness
to a few of them myself.
They are rapid fire.
They are witty.
They're performative.
And they're a kick to behold.
>> Right.
>> The student went
on to write, quote,
"He really makes you wonder
about the things the
world has to offer."
Indeed. And you're
in for a treat.
Please welcome Tom Keegan.
[ Applause ]
>> Tom Keegan: And it is hard.
I'm not sure I can follow my
own introduction [laughter].
All right.
Is this, is this, what's --
is there a pointer up
here, or was there?
>> I don't [inaudible]
something.
>> Tom Keegan: Oh, oh,
this thing in front of me.
Is that what you -- okay.
Okay. So thank you very much.
I want to say thank you
to the Library of Congress
and thank you very much
to Stephanie Stillo
for putting this together and
giving me this opportunity.
It's a total delight to be here,
made even moreso by the kind
of homecoming that I get
to experience with Nicki
who had the job I
have now previously.
I'm not sure I'm due all
that praise, either from her
or my students, but
I will take it.
And I'm glad that Nicki began
with teaching, because a lot
of my talk is going to be
about what we do with the stuff
that we're doing
in my department.
So I want to talk a little bit
about what you're
going to see here.
All these slides come from
the holding of the University
of Iowa Libraries, in particular
the John Martin Rare Book Room
and the UI Special Collections.
But to get them here requires
a particular degree of labor
that I would be remiss if
I didn't point that out.
So just as we're talking about
the process by which some
of these things are drawn,
I think it's important
to acknowledge as a
librarian who's connected
to the digital endeavor
that nothing you're going
to see here didn't first
come out of the vault,
go through the hands
of conservators
and preservationists, move into
digitization which takes place
at our library in
Preservation an Conservation,
then get handled by Library
Information Technology,
the catalogers, until
we finally move it
into the Iowa Digital Library
where -- and/or DIY History.
So it takes a lot of
people to get that done.
And I think sometimes it's, when
we have nice high-res photos
and they're visually
captivating,
I think sometimes we
miss intentionally
because it would be weird if
you were looking at at image
that seemed very difficult
in its manifestation.
But I think I kind
of want to just start
by acknowledging that.
And we are fortunate at
Iowa, as Nicki pointed out,
to have a kind of growing
digital presence and operation.
A lot of that starts with,
for here -- I want to --
-- talk about -- the first thing
I'll talk about with respect
to her is stuff that comes
out of the John Martin
Rare Book Room.
That stuff is the most germane
to I think the broad topic
of this symposium, even though
I'm going to diverge, I think,
kind of wildly, well,
relatively wildly,
after these next few slides.
The John Martin Rare Book Room
has over 6500 original works,
and these are --
that Rare Book Room,
it's kind of like the
special collections
of our Health Sciences Library.
It's situated on the west half
of campus by the hospital.
And it includes things like
what you see here in the back
of this, or, you know, the
background of this slide.
Giovanni Alfonso
Borelli's engravings
from De Motu Animalium
, 1680 to 1681.
And this volume is designed
to showcase humans and animals
in various positions of
muscle exertion with an eye
to physics rather than anatomy.
And so what we're seeing
in these illustrations
is the expansion
of the enlightenment's
desire to classify and define
and understand humanity through
representation and scale,
which -- that's not new news.
We've been hearing about that
throughout the presentations.
So we've been digitizing
stuff like this.
I'll show you a few
other examples.
What you have here
is an illustration
from Georg Bartisch's 1583 work,
Ophthalmodouleia: Das ist,
Augendienst , and it
has I think 92 woodcuts.
One here. And they're executed,
believed to have been executed
by Hans Hemmerwahl
[assumed spelling]
after Bartisch's own drawings.
You can see here that -- I
think you can see in the shadows
that there are super-imposed
flaps, so this is close
to where -- you know we're
talking 16th century [inaudible]
about the anatomy and
operation of the eye.
I also, just in -- [inaudible]
remarkable, I also want to point
out that despite or in addition
to its scientific merits,
Bartisch was into, and a
believer in, things like magic,
astrology, and witchcraft.
And I don't -- I'm not
trying to knock him.
I'm also not like advocating
for a belief in magic,
but I want to point out
that when we're talking
about the sciences, we're
talking about a kind of broad
and varied terrain which
is constantly changing.
My wife is a Classics Professor
and she wanted me to make sure
that everyone was aware that
the word science is right
from the Greek and Latin
for -- word for knowing.
And so when we're talking
about science we're talking
about forms of knowing.
And I think that that will come
across throughout a
number of the slides.
Here's another example
of stuff that's
in the John Martin
Rare Book Room.
This is Gasper --
these are two plates
from Caspar Schott
Physica Curioso in 1697
which itself is not an
original scholarly work so much
as a collection of commonly-held
beliefs or thoughts
about monsters, physical
abnormalities,
and bizarre animals.
And so, again, I see this
as a kind of, you know --
it's located in the
Rare Book Room.
It's an illustration of
this evolving imagination
with respect to zoology and
things that are taking place
in the world complete
with satyrs and centaurs.
One more example or
two more examples here.
We also have these two plates.
The one on the left is Andre
de Bois-Regard's 1751 --
it comes from the work
Orthopedics or the Art
of Preventing and Corrupting
in Children Deformities
of the Body .
And you also have on the right
Bernhard Siegfried Albinus's
Tables of the Skeleton and
Muscles of the Human Body .
And here to the left,
most of the book,
most of Bois-Regard's work is
interested in this [inaudible],
is interested in preventing and
correcting poor body posture
and other defects caused
by improper habits during
children's formative years;
As you can, I think see,
she's balancing a book
on her head in that one.
On the right you have --
this engraving's by Yan
Wandalarr [assumed spelling].
A depiction of the human
skeleton complete with a natural
and Renaissance stylization
for which, I believe,
he was criticized for
including that kind of stuff.
In any case, so that's --
this is as professional as
it gets from here on out.
And so I wanted to
point this out thought
that across all these --
whatever their scientific merit,
there is this ongoing interest
in defining and categorizing
and uncovering an understanding
of our place in the world.
And I think that's
imaginative in nature.
So that being said, I should
-- the title of my talk is,
"Strong in Their
Lowliness, Everyday People,
Everyday Illustration."
And I don't -- I mean my
illustrations don't look
like this.
So I thought we would
get to some
that come closer
to that reality.
Okay. So Nicki mentions
DIY History.
And I want to talk a
little bit about that.
It began about six
years ago as an attempt
by Special Collections working
with a version of my department
that Nicki was running
then to get the public
to transcribe Civil War
letters and diaries.
The idea being that this
stuff is manuscript.
It's not text searchable.
How do you get -- you don't
get a Librarian to do that.
No one is like, aw, you can
definitely pay me a salary.
Just sit down and transcribe
thousands of pages of Civil War.
I mean that would be cool if
that were a job, but that's not
where the money's
going in the library.
So these things were
digitized and made public.
And over the years
we've expanded the scope
of that process.
So now beyond Civil War letters
and diaries, we have things
like -- this is a
World War II letter.
But most recently I think our
newest collection is the Hevelin
Fanzine's collection,
so these are --
I'll talk a little bit about
that at the end of the talk,
but they were talking about
10,000-plus zines that --
from the 1930s to
the present day.
And so we've been
digitizing these things
and making them public.
And the public, as Nicki
said, has transcribed
over 80,000 pages for which
we are incredibly grateful.
And we think of it now less
as a transcription platform
than we do a public
engagement platform.
So how do we get the
public interacting
with exploring the contents
of these collections
because otherwise, if we had
not digitized these things
and made them public,
they're sitting in a vault,
and we're hoping that the
subject guides are sufficient
to seduce you into
the Reading Room.
And that's not always the case.
This letter -- and I think
there's some unique things
in here.
So this letter is
from August 14, 1942,
and it is from Laura Davis
to her husband, Lloyd,
about two months
after he was drafted.
I don't know if you
can read the cursive.
I know that's going
out of fashion.
Good night, Laddie.
Off to the post office
so you will have a letter
arriving on schedule.
And then at the bottom
you'll see the stick figures
which I'm counting
as an illustration.
And it says, my place here.
Ready? To which the larger
figure says, yes, honey.
And the response, good Laddie.
And I know you're thinking
like oh, that's amusing,
but it's not scientific
illustration.
That's doodling.
And I'm willing to agree at
this moment in the presentation
that that's the case,
though I plan to bring you
over to my side by
the end [laughter].
What I want to point out
is that these doodles --
what I want to try
and argue here is
that these doodles are a part
of a long process of the science
of human communication and
understanding, and a process
that -- amongst all the
other things that we've seen
and will see, also includes
the marginal and the mundane.
But before I inflict that
on you, I want to talk
about this kind of stuff.
Two years ago -- a few
years ago this month,
for Women's History Month,
we made public 3000 --
we dumped into the
L.A History 3000 pages
of manuscript material
that had been digitized
but nothing was really
going on with them.
And this material was -- this
material is undergraduate
and graduate thesis material
from the 1880s and '90s,
predominantly about science and
predominantly written by women
at what was then called the
State University of Iowa,
which is now the
University of Iowa.
So this [inaudible] sitting
there and I said, well,
we've got to make this public.
This is too cool.
I think this is important.
So, you know, we shared
this and I wrote a --
I was writing some
blog posts about it,
and we were putting it
out on social media.
And I had the occasion to
talk to a faculty member
from a different institution.
So I was not [inaudible] faculty
to my mind I'm not guilty
of this, but I spoke
to a faculty member
about this collection.
And he said, well
that's -- sure.
What's the scientific --
the sell-by date's
passed on that, you know.
The [inaudible] of Iowa
city and vicinity of thesis
by Annette Slaughterbeck in 1888
is no longer scientifically,
you know, useful.
And I -- fine, you know,
that the kind of --
I think librarians
like those kinds
of softball snide
comments [laughter].
It's like it's not --
we're not preserving it
because I think someone's
going to mine it
for scientific data about moss.
This is something
that, you know,
we do this because
it's a artifact
that illustrates what students
at the institution were doing.
But when they were
doing in science
at our particular institution
at a time when we're talking
about STEM or STEAM, here's
a vivid example, I think,
of that kind of work and labor.
And that itself is a
historical artifact that's
worth preserving.
It's captivating
past that because
of how these things are
constructed on the process
by which students were
constructing these things.
So I want to -- I want
to just -- let's see.
I want to show you this.
The title for the talk
comes from her thesis,
her undergraduate thesis.
And the quote that begins
it, strong in her lowliness,
is taken by her from
John Ruskin,
the famous Victorian art critic.
Line five of his
Modern Painters ,
the section leaves motionless.
Okay. So she starts quoting
Ruskin and she writes,
"Strong in her lowliness"
-- that part's from Ruskin.
And this is her.
The humble little plants passed
every damn thoughtlessness
and indifference through
an important place
in the category of nature.
Carelessly scattered
in waste spots
and lonely unvisited haunts,
clinging to the rocky slopes
or lingering by the
water's edge,
slowly and unconsciously they
fulfill the mission entrusted
to their care.
Peacemakers they are, rounding
the sharp edges of the rocks,
filling cracks and
crevices in the wake --
following in the wake
of rain and decay
in their painful traces.
And then she quotes
Ruskin again.
"Covering with strange
and tender honor the
scarred disgrace of ruin,
laying their quiet finger
on the trembling stones
to teach them rest."
So that's cool, right.
Jesus Christ.
That's like -- my
dissertation does not --
my dissertation reads like that
garbage Nicki quoted, you know,
"the paternal token --
paternalistic token
of Irish drunkenness."
That line of Ruskin's,
"strong in their lowliness,"
I think that's a
totally beautiful line,
and clearly Annette
Slaughterbeck thought so, too.
And I think that idea of
acknowledging the lowliest flora
and it's role in shaping
the larger world is equally
beautiful and wonderful.
I think it is also wonderful
to watch and to observe
on these pages the mind of
this undergraduate Bachelor
of Science candidate weave
together prose inspired
by an art critic with
illustrations derived
from hundreds of years of
scientific observation.
I don't care about these things
for their scientific
content any more than I care
about the scientific content
of Renaissance-era [inaudible]
and engravers capturing the
human imagination one zoological
bestiary at a time.
That's not the point.
The point is I'm
interested in the process.
There's a care and personality
in these illustrations.
And regardless of the scientific
contribution they may make
today, they continue to
have merit in their ability
to help us see ourselves,
and particular
to help see how students
see themselves in the past.
A student looking at this
today might well recognize
in their own mediocre
talents or [inaudible], the --
you know, the --
their own abilities
in these illustrations.
In doing so they see
themselves in a form of thing
in these illustrations.
And that is why we preserve and
share outdated scientific work
by undergraduate women working
in the sciences at the edge
of the 19th century, and
why I want my students
to see themselves as part
of a much longer story
about human inquiry
and endeavor, okay?
And I just have a few
more examples from this.
This is another -- this is Ann
B. Jewett's 1890 thesis called
The Sun Flower As a Type
of Flowering Plants."
And it includes this
like lovely water coloring
and in this nice poem which
reads, "And as the sunflower
in some barren field
lights up the waste
with cheerful golden glow."
She also has detailed
cross-section drawings
of parenchyma cells and on
the right you'll see the spiral
arrangement of leaves
on a stem.
And so students here
are seeing, you know,
this kind of studious,
hand-drawn,
attentive engagement
with the sciences.
And I think that that should
be hope resonate with them.
You can see it as well in Nelly
Peery's, The Fertilizing Cell,
Its Form and Behavior
in these drawings.
And in the Curious Observations
of Minapee [assumed spelling]
Humphry's "The Slime Molds
of Eastern Iowa , okay?
She had to do your
work on something.
And so these, these are not --
these are not throwaway records
of amateur scientists.
These are part of a much longer
imagination about human endeavor
and a glimpse into
the everyday work.
These are not famous people.
Annette Slaughterbeck
goes on to get a degree
in Temperance Science, and is
a German and Science Teacher
in the high school in
Illinois later in life.
So these things are valuable.
I think they're part of
the historical record
in the conversation
about illustration.
But they're very germane
to those opening slides.
I want to kind of
push the definition
or weaken the definition or
bring lower the definition
of scientific illustration.
So I went, excuse me, so I
went looking for other things.
And that brought me to letters,
other letters and diaries.
So I wanted to find these
strongly mundane forms.
And we have an example here.
This is an August 13,
1918 letter from Walter
Fox to his wife, Bess.
And it details that,
that u-shaped,
w-shaped thing is a
detail of his barracks
at Fort Sill in Oklahoma.
And so I was looking at this,
and I said, you know, okay,
why -- the doodle
got me thinking.
Why does Fox doodle this?
And I think in part he
does it because words fail
at different moments when we
constructing these things.
He's trying to give his wife
a picture of his surroundings.
He's trying to document his
lived experience and working
within the economy of space
that is a letter he
uses illustrations
to convey that reality.
I'll show you another one.
This was another unexpected one.
This is an illustration
from Jackson Harrison
Alspaugh's 1865 diary
in which he captures Old Tom,
Company H's pack
mule through Georgia.
Alspaugh was member of the
31st Ohio Infantry Regiment
in the Civil War, and
participated in Sherman's March
to the Sea, which, if you're
familiar with the line ascribed
to Sherman about 40 acres
and a mule for freed slaves,
then this takes on another
kind of historical resonance.
But we're not -- we don't --
it's not a history
lecture so much
as just how do pictures kind
of arrest the imagination
and draw us into
those conversations?
Here's another one, but,
again, has deeper context.
But when I was digging
through [inaudible] history,
this is what I saw first,
and I saw a picture.
This is good.
I need more signs.
This though was found in the --
this comes from Thomas
Clark Durant's miscellaneous
correspondence of 1872 to
1899, and I didn't off the top
of my head know who
Thomas Clark Durant is.
Some of you may.
He was kind of a
railroad tycoon.
Okay, he's responsible --
he's the Vice President of
the Union Pacific Railroad.
He was friends with
Abraham Lincoln
and Lincoln gets him the deal
to begin the first
transcontinental railroad.
He is also -- he was a cotton
smuggler during the Civil War.
He was involved in the
Credit Mobilier Scandal.
He manipulated the Stock Market.
He was not a particularly
charismatic --
well, maybe he was very
charismatic, but not a, not a,
you know, an ethical
person which, I suppose,
if you're a railroad
person you're probably not.
But what is great about this is
this is directions to himself
on how to unlock his
safe which is probably --
if you're him, you probably
want to make sure you know how.
So what he's written here is,
you know, "To unlock the safe,
screw the knob on thus
and insert the key as far
into the keyhole as possible
and turn to the left.
The letter U on knob
must stand upright
to insert or withdraw the key."
And, again, while that's not
groundbreaking scientific
illustration, it's interesting
to see how everyday people are
using illustrations to kind
of convey meaning and
method in their daily lives.
This is from some
correspondence from 1880
from the Bean [assumed
spelling] Family letters
in which two brothers
are discussing how best
to put a roof on a barn.
So the letter reads,
"It may be best to carry
up the octagonal gable
thus as to pitch.
But I'm not as yet
satisfied without the drawings
which would really
be the best way.
The dotted lines are for
a uniform pitch of roof.
And the other is a peaked pitch
so as to have the ridge come
out even with the
sides of the building.
And, again, not a
remarkable thing.
But I'm no architect,
but I [inaudible]
if that's not a scientific
illustration.
I want to show you -- so,
again, so now we're getting,
now we're back to doodles.
These are -- well you can see.
We have a collection of
smiley faces, frowny faces,
and other faces which to
me are precursors of one
of the most substantial
technological innovations
of the 21st century and a lingua
franca of our times, the emoji.
And so I think this stand
in similarly as examples
of people using art
to fill the gaps
when words will not
or cannot do.
These, in particular, are
letters from the First
and Second World Wars in
which men and women try
to bring themselves as close
as they can to one another.
In the first letter on the left,
Laura David, who, you know,
is from one of those earlier
slides, write to her husband.
"Tell me what to
write or how to write
if you wish I would
write differently.
I want the letters to
help and to be good
so that you are glad
when they come.
Smiley Face not Frowny
Face [laughter].
Yeah, right?
I have written here, that is
wonderfully mundane poignancy,
right?
There is like --
in that sentiment.
There are -- there is John
Graham's letter of December 7,
1942, and this is at the --
up on the top left there,
where he's writing to
his wife about the antics
of his company in 1942.
"Makes it kind of touch on the
image of a Sergeant's stripes,
but no one seems to care."
And that idea that you'd
let the image stand
in for the person I
think is quite elegant.
You also see, in talking
about public engagement,
those two images at the bottom
are from Daphne Reynolds
to her husband Conger
Reynolds in 1918.
And the one on the -- you'll
see the one on the bottom right,
the one on the bottom right --
well, I'll tell you
how that's defined
by a transcriber
here in a minute.
The one on the bottom left
is a crying face that --
I don't know if you can see it.
The tears are labelled tears.
In case that -- well, I don't
know what else would be conveyed
there, but she made sure
that he got the message.
But the one on the bottom
right is a letter to Conger
from Daphne in which she's
talking about how difficult --
he has to appreciate how
difficult it is for her
to have recently given
up candy and ice cream.
And every time she
passes the shop,
you know, how tough that is.
And so she writes, "Do pat me
on the back a little, dearest."
And then there's that kind of --
that face which a transcriber,
and this is the beautiful
part about the Iowa history
and how the public
reads these images.
The transcriber put in
brackets, [smug face],
which I -- which I love.
I'm can say okay.
If you think so, okay.
That says a lot.
As -- all it -- say something
about the translator.
But, again, in these letters,
I think that it's interesting
to see everyday art in the
science of human presence
in these difficult spaces or
places where words fail us.
Another example along
these lines --
this is a letter from George
Davis to his brother, Lloyd,
and June 1st, 1944, and this is
towards the end of the letter.
George has already
signed off at this point,
but he's got a post-script.
And he signs in this
post-script --
he says, "Still get to draw like
we did when we went to school,"
and there's this animal.
"It is funny.
When I am working in the field,
there are a dozen things I want
to tell you, but when I start
to write, I don't know nothing."
And I think that just beneath
those off-the-cuff sentiments
lurks kind of real
emotion, and it's hard not
to freight those -- when
you read them in context,
it's hard not to
freight the doodles
with a meaning past
their seeming lowliness.
These are examples from --
so we're looking at
people writing to soldiers.
These are examples of
soldiers writing back home,
and these come from
the Civil War,
World War -- up to World War II.
And in them -- we won't
go through all of them,
because I'm conscious
of time here --
men are detailing their
battlefields, camps,
their movements in foreign
countries, flight formations,
as in the top the left there.
And on the left, plans to
fix up Aunt Maude's garden
in Wyandotte [assumed spelling].
So in the incident to the
left here, the garden,
you have Burton J. Smith
[assumed spelling] writing
to his fiancee, Williametta
Turnipseed [assumed spelling] --
and that is -- I promise you,
that is her name [laughter].
And this is, like, a
super-poignant story.
I won't -- he dies, sadly,
on the day she writes him,
which I hate to do
after laughter.
It's like, her name's Turnipseed
-- oh, he passed away.
But he dies in a plane crash,
but throughout the world,
we have all these really
remarkable letters between them.
But in this one, just to give
you a sense -- so here he is --
that's him -- that
flight formation is him,
but this garden is him as well.
And in the letter, he says --
you know, he has this
bit about the garden.
He says, "As you can see,
my mind is wandering,
making plans again."
But just prior to that, he's
writing about what's happening
at the time, and he
says -- he -- let's see.
Where are we?
"I am still on the flight line.
The hurricane is expected
about 2:00 p.m. We will
soon be taking off.
Motors are roaring.
Everything that can
fly is going.
About 4:00 a.m., all those
ships, on which only one motor
of the two would run, limped
off to a safer place."
And amidst all -- that's
in the same letter.
Amidst all this, he's
sketching plans for a garden,
you know, his aunt's garden.
Which I think -- again, if
we're talking about science
in illustration, I find
that a telling illustration
of human consciousness, and
how we think about things,
and what preoccupies us, and
how we communicate our way
of being in the world.
So we looked at letters
and diaries.
I also started looking at
notebooks and cookbooks,
and so -- as another kind of
lowly form of illustration.
And so, this slide is a
doodle by James Van Allen,
who was a physicist and former
professor at the University
of Iowa, who helped --
who was instrumental
in studying the radiation
belts that circle the Earth
and prevent us from dying,
and they bear his name,
the Van Allen radiation belts.
So these are -- we have
Van Allen's very extensive
collection of his papers, and
among them, we have notebooks
of his, which we have digitized,
and the public has transcribed.
I should point out that
the doodle is not actually
of the belts.
It is a Swedish penholder
that is carefully documented
and measured in one
of his journals.
You can see we have -- he has a
four-inch scale at the bottom,
and he has labeled the holes.
But I -- I just think this --
interesting illustration
of the scientific mind,
and we're going to
come back to him.
But I want to show you
this cookbook first.
So we have another collection
called the Szathmary Culinary
Collection, which has a
number of cookbooks in it,
stretching back to
the 17th century.
And a 17th century
cookbook, in some instances,
reads like a survival guide
more than a recipe book.
But this one is fascinating
to me.
This comes in from -- this is
from the Willis family recipe
books, 1833 to 1861, and it --
here's the writer, is
grappling with the phenomenon
of negative afterimages.
Okay, so when you
stare at something,
and you close your eyes,
and you see the inverse
of that image colorscape --
so this was written
in the cookbook.
"The fluctuation of colors
at the border of patterns,
when the ground and the pattern
are of complementary colors,
so that if a red wafer
is laid on a white paper
in a strong light, and looked at
for some time, and then removed,
the eye, now looking on the
paper, receives the white light
over the part of the eye when
the red image was before.
But the red portion of that
white light produces less
than its proper effect.
Consequently, there
appears a greenish spot
where the red wafer was."
And so, the hashing out of this
scientific experiment goes on,
and then there's a subject
of an amusing experiment.
"A very amusing illustration
of the property
of the complementary colors
may thus be made on a paper
about twice the size of
a sheet of note paper.
Draw a rough figure.
Paint every part with
bright colors complementary
to what the colors ought
to be, as green cheeks,
white of the eye, black -- a
black cap, a red ribbon green,
a green gown red, and so on,
a very black frame
pattern all around.
Then lay this on the
floor in a strong light.
Look for some time, then
put up to the ceiling --
then look up to the ceiling.
And in a minute, you will
see a spectral picture
with all the colors right.
This requires a little practice,
and some eyes see it
better than other -- "
-- with the -- I think,
the closing line there,
with some wry candor,
"young eyes best."
So this is great.
I love these instructions that
are -- you know, these weird,
unanticipated illustrations
creeping
into these mundane spaces.
And these are Van Allen.
Now, Van Allen -- no one's
calling him an amateur
scientist, okay?
He's pre-NASA.
He's involved in the
U.S.'s first satellite.
He is instrumental, as I
said, in space exploration
in the U.S., and globally.
But these are doodles, you
know, from his notebooks, and,
you know, he's got
things in here --
I don't want to walk through
all the illustrations.
But he's sketching
crude manometers,
square-wave frequency
calculations, radio antennae,
and a bunch of other
technical concerns.
When we show these
things to students --
or why we'd want to show
them to the public is
to help them understand
the ad hoc, immediate,
and improvisational
character of a process,
that the work is not
always so clearly-defined.
It is a muddle, and you work
things through in shorthand.
So I think it's important
to be able to share
that kind of material.
And since we're talking about
space, I wanted to go to just,
you know, the last section.
I want to talk about
the Hevelin fanzines,
which may be more jarring,
because these look
a bit more coherent,
but they're also further afield.
The James L. Rusty Hevelin
Collection at the University
of Iowa contains about --
over 10,000 science fiction,
as I said, fantasy
and horror zines,
collected by Rusty Hevelin.
He was this uber-fan,
and took everything,
and we were happy
to have it from him.
Recently the University of Iowa
Library's made the decision
to make about 6000 pages
of this material available,
so we digitized these things and
turned them out to the public.
Many of them are deeply --
if we're talking
about lowly objects,
these are deeply
ephemeral materials.
They are mimeographed, and
in most cases, stapled,
and published in
small quantities.
Like, some -- for instance, this
is a cover from "Fan Slants" --
this is the back cover, I
should say, of "Fan Slants,"
had a three-issue run.
This is from September
1943, and it features --
I don't know if you can tell.
I think you can -- has a
ghost reading people stories,
clearly shocked at
what it is discovering
in those morbid pages.
But I love that title,
"People Stories,"
because my argument would be
that that's what 'zines are.
They are people stories.
That's what these -- the
fantastical, the imaginary,
the horrific -- we create
these things in an effort
to better understand
ourselves, and I also dig
that it's got a memento
mori, this --
you know, the death
trope that is --
it's also artistically
present in history, I think,
or influenced by
what's come before.
But so -- these are a couple
examples of zines that are,
you know, showing us where
the cultural imagination is
at the time, and how we're
understanding our place
in the world.
These are also people who saw --
and Lovecraft is an
absolute touchstone
for this fan community, and
they saw him as an illustrator.
And so, I just wanted to
include -- this is a --
these are illustrations by
H.P. Lovecraft, and they ran --
this is a letter they ran.
This comes from "Acolyte,"
volume one, issue four,
in which -- the summer of
1943, titled "Lovecraft
as Illustrator,"
and it's a reprint
from a letter Lovecraft
wrote in 1934.
I want to share just part
of this letter with you,
because it's interesting to
hear Lovecraft, a horror writer,
you know, weird -- the father,
in part, of weird fiction,
describe what he thinks
he is as an illustrator.
"I feel tremendously and
undeservedly flattered
by your kindly mention of
the crude and casual sketch
in my letter to Rimmel.
I've always wished I could draw,
but have no natural aptitude
for it, so that despite
infinite pains, my best efforts
in that direction are rather
ludicrous and pathetic.
Odd, too, from my grandmother,
great aunt, and late elder aunt,
were all accomplished artists,
while my father's sketchbooks
attest his very passable skill
with a pencil.
It makes me green with envy
when I see certain
naturally-gifted persons
effortlessly translate a
visual impression to paper.
When I try the same thing,
the result is an awkward mess
of forced pen scratches.
I have always envied authors who
can illustrate their own tales,
pulling into visibility
exactly what they have in mind,
instead of depending on the
routine work, often careless,
uncomprehending,
and unsympathetic,
of magazine illustrators.
But I have scarcely
hoped to be able
to produce anything
suitable myself.
I'm under no illusions
as to the inaptitude
of my unschooled
pictorial blunderings."
And so, despite how
harsh he is on himself,
this is a community that's
interested in illustration,
interested in trying to
communicate what's inside
of them, and what
they're thinking about.
And it's not so far afield, I
think, from where we started,
if you think of Albanus's
centaur, or satyrs,
or where the cultural historical
imagination lies with respect
to what counts as
knowing the world.
I have you literally
covered, because here again,
we have two covers, this one
on the left from "Venus,"
volume one, issue one, from
1944, featuring a centaur,
and on the right, "Le
Zombie," volume five,
issue four, January 1943.
Again, with these
ideas, and these figures
in different contexts, but still
part of that longer history.
It's hard not to see
in this history --
for instance, on the left,
R.A. Hoffman's cover for
"Acolyte" volume one,
issue four, summer of 1943,
the kind of attention to
cellular, microbial detail
that we saw earlier
in something like one
of Nelly Piery's
[assumed spelling] looking
at the fertilizing cell.
Or the anatomical observations
in Nils Helmer Frome's cover for
"Canadian Fandom" at the top
in 1947, or the influence
of biological study in Clark
Ashton Smith's alien creature
in the pages of "Acolyte" two,
issue four, 1944 at the bottom.
These zines are awash
in the fantastical,
but perhaps no moreso than any
other -- any of the illustrators
or scientists we'll
see or have seen today,
and coming up tomorrow.
All of them, it seems to
me, are addressing our place
in the world, whether
real or surreal --
which today are continually
confused, I think --
but I want to end on
this idea of sight.
We saw that Bartrich
and Hamoval's [assumed
spelling] eye, with the flaps,
and I thought this was too
good not to share with you.
This is a story by -- I
assume this is a penname,
Jean St. Jean [assumed
spelling],
called "The Discerning Eye,"
from the March-April 1942
issue of "The Comet."
In this brief story, Paul
Dunlop, an amateur chemist,
prone to verbal mania, a sad
disease which afflicts someone
with a propensity for
big words, falls victim
to a horrible accident that
allows him supernatural sight.
He can see the table, quote,
"composed of multitudinous,
tiny, active organisms."
He comes to see the
Earth, quote,
"with a great seething mass."
The impact -- it drives him mad,
which is where these
stories often go.
But -- so his wife finds him
covered in this chemical,
and she's asked him can he see.
And he shouts to her, "'See!
The magic word, see!
Not view, observe,
look on, but see!'
In the excitement of the
moment, he forgot large words.
He began another deep
chuckle, submerged in the depth
of his chest, and as
it reached his peak,
he realized the tremendous
force he possessed,
the various possibilities
of his state of being.
No more days at the office."
[Laughter] Love that's
where you go, first thing.
"No more odious hypocrisy.
No more fetid miasma
of pretension.
He could see in.
His sight was an eruption,
a scientific hyperbole,
but a truth.
He had no walls to contain his
sight, no bonds to bind him.
He could look through
anything, or anyone,
and his peculiarity
was permanent.
This, he could feel.
Nothing could maintain
his sight.
What a power he had!
And when they led
him to the asylum --
" [laughter] that's
the next sentence.
"And he protested, as always,
to their imbecilic fallacy.
The gates closed with a final
click on the man who could look
through the strongest
walls, the stoutest barrier,
but he could only look."
Now, despite that
dark ending for Paul,
I truly appreciate the crazed
emphasis on sight here.
Perhaps if we, like Paul,
look more closely into the --
to quote again, "waste spots
and lonely, unvisited haunts,"
into the, dare I say,
archives and collections
that contain these lowliest
forms of illustration.
We will come to discover new
ways at looking at things --
oh, new ways of looking
at things, and new ways
of recognizing ourselves
and our world
from the elegant engravings
to the most fleeting doodles,
all of them revealing
a kind of strength
in our earthly presence.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Abigail Potter: Hello.
I am Abby Potter.
I'm the acting chief
of the National Digital
Initiatives here at the Library
of Congress, also known as
the Library of Congress Labs,
and I have the pleasure to
introduce our next speaker
and her talk, which is called
"Storytelling with Science."
Eleanor Lutz is a Ph.D.
candidate at the University
of Washington, studying biology,
specifically studying
how mosquitoes learn
and remember new experiences.
Lutz also runs the incredible
science illustration blog,
"Tabletop Whale."
Here, you can see her work,
which has also been published
in "National Geographic,"
"Scientific American,"
and "The Gates Foundation."
Her work adds a sense of wonder
and playfulness to science
by finding inspiration in
historical science illustrations
and art movements, while also
ensuring they're accurate
by working directly with
scientists and doctors.
Let's also include
digital design techniques,
such as animation and
programming in her work.
Today, Lutz will speak to
us about finding the balance
between artistic styling
and scientific convention,
celebrating the complexity
of scientific research,
and combining digital
design technology
with traditional art styles.
Eleanor?
[ Applause ]
>> Eleanor Lutz: Okay.
Hi, everyone.
Thank you, Abby, for
the introduction.
It's really nice
to be here today.
So I make science
illustrations, like this one.
This one shows you how
grasshoppers breathe using this
very complicated
network of air tubes,
instead of having any lungs
or blood vessels, like we use.
And it's not the most
efficient system, but it works,
because insects are pretty small
and don't use a lot of oxygen.
And I make a lot of animated
infographics like this one,
but I've also done a
few static illustrations
for science articles
in magazines.
And today, I want to
talk to you about some
of the things I personally
have learned
through making these
infographics.
So first, I'll talk a
little about how I got
into science illustration in
the first place, and then I'd
like to talk about
some of the things
that I think are the main
challenges for me when I try
to make these projects,
and how I try
to address those challenges
while working on something.
So I got into making
science illustrations more
from the science side than
from an art background.
I got my bachelor's
degree in molecular
and developmental biology,
broadly studying how people
and animals grow and change
throughout their lives.
So I've always been
really interested
in these really intricate
processes that are happening
around us, and in our
own bodies every day.
So processes like this one,
where lifting a cup of coffee,
or just your arm, where these
trillions of tiny molecules,
and fibers, and molecular
machinery are really working
together to make your movements
look seamless and easy.
Or how everyone sitting
here today developed
into a functioning human from
just a tiny cluster of cells.
So here in this graphic,
you start at the top right,
as a fertilized egg, and
it animates the process
of embryo development
all the way to birth,
at the center of the diagram.
And I really think it's kind
of incredible that we all went
through this very complicated
developmental process before we
were even born, and so for me,
design is really a way for me
to share these really
awesome science stories.
And I like to try and share
them in a way that uses color
or movement, and really tries
to uncouple the technical jargon
from what's actually happening,
and what the science
actually means.
And when I'm making
these infographics,
there are really two challenges
that I think are the
most difficult for me,
and the two questions,
really, that I try to think
about when I work on a project.
So the first challenge
for me is really
to decide what information
belongs in a graphic.
I think we have such
a huge, you know,
library of scientific
information,
and it's very difficult to
pick out an individual story
that makes sense, and in
particular, to pick out a story
in a way that's, like,
respectful to the science,
and also to the audience.
So I think a good infographic
really lets you pay attention
to what's really important,
and it does that by removing
everything else that's
less relevant.
And the second challenge
that I try to really think
about logically is
picking an art style
that really complements
the science.
I want -- okay, I want to
find a way of, you know,
connecting the art and the
science, in a way where both
of them are kind of talking
together in a conversation, and,
you know, the graphics is
actually an integrated part
of the science story.
Okay, so between these
two, you know, challenges
or overall goals, I want to talk
about the information first,
and I want to convince you
that this really is, like,
a big challenge to distill this
information, and that this is,
like, a very big constraint
in making these science
illustrations.
Because there are a lot
of other constraints
in making an infographic.
Obviously, there's
things like the deadline,
or the size of what
you're allowed to work on,
but there's also things like
vocabulary, the amount of text.
And of all these different
constraints in a project,
I still think that
deciding what to remove
in the first place is
really the most difficult.
And to give you a more concrete
example, here's two examples
of some really complicated
science figures
that I personally really love.
On the left is a food network by
David Levine [assumed spelling].
I'm not sure if you
can see that,
but it's a food network based --
it's intended to talk
about the codfish,
which is near the
center of the diagram.
And it's really -- its purpose
is to show you the huge variety
of animals and organisms that
are interacting with each other
in a natural food network.
And we usually see, like,
a simplified food network,
where only a couple different
species, maybe the most common
or important predator/prey
relationships,
but in the real world, there's
actually a lot more going on.
And this one on the right --
it's a diagram of
all the neurons
in a tiny nematode
worm called C. elegans.
The worm's only about
a millimeter long,
and it has more or
less 300 neurons.
And this kind of network diagram
of neurons is called
a connectome,
and the C. elegans
worm is special,
because it's the only
animal where all of these --
all these nodes have
been mapped in this way.
And in this map, each of these
colors tells you a little bit
about what's -- what each
of the nodes stands for.
So the purple on the edges of
the diagram are the muscles.
The yellow are the
motor neurons,
which are telling the
muscles what to do.
The blue are the neurons
that are gathering
sensory information
from the environment.
They're detecting things like
touch, or smell, and the orange
and interneurons, which connect
all of these other things,
and make up this very
complicated diagram
that helps this tiny worm move
throughout its environment
and make decisions.
Okay, I want to show you
just one more picture
of a complicated science
diagram, and bear with me,
because it's my favorite one.
[Laughter] It's a
molecular diagram.
It's about all the things
that happen inside your body
when you digest some food and
turn it into molecular energy.
And I love this because I
studied molecular biology.
I really like the idea that
when you zoom down far enough
into our own bodies, we --
all of us look like this really
crazy, complicated network
of molecules, and
chemicals, and interactions.
And all of these are -- you
know, different things happen
when you eat a protein
versus a sugar, like --
and these are, like, all
represented in this diagram.
I actually didn't even
include the whole thing.
It's cropped.
Okay. But as much as
I love this figure,
it's too much information.
It's just -- like,
nobody can look at this
and process it all at once.
That's -- I don't
think that's possible.
So a useful infographic to me
is never an accurate, like,
complete representation
of all of the science.
It's -- it has to be curated
in some way to be useful.
So the first thing I try to do
when I plan an infographic
is really think
about my particular
audience for that project,
and what they really need.
And, you know, most people
don't need all of this,
and it's actually more
helpful to get rid
of the things you don't need.
And depending on the audience,
that can mean very
different things.
So here's my attempt at
turning that molecular diagram
into something a
little more reasonable.
This is a story for
medical students.
So it's part of a series of
20 different posters I made
in collaboration with a company
called Nerd Corp Medical.
And the point of these posters
was to work as kind of a large,
you know, interesting
picture that people could put
up on their walls, but
also use as a study guide
for medical licensing exams.
So that's a very specific
audience, with a very, you know,
detailed and clear set of goals.
And because the audience
is so specific,
I haven't actually removed
too much information.
What I've done here is gone
through and picked out several
of the chemical pathways,
like the TZA cycle,
that you would probably
need to know
for a medical licensing
exam, and I've removed a lot
of the pathways that you
probably wouldn't need to know,
or are less important,
or less known.
But in the pathways
that I did include,
I didn't actually
remove a whole lot
of the information
inside each pathway.
So I still have things like
the names of all the molecules,
the intermediate
chemicals, like even things
like how much molecular
energy each step would take.
And these are all things I
would probably have removed
if this was for a
more general audience,
because I think this is still
a really complicated graphic
that's hard to understand.
But since the intended
audience here was really medical
students, I needed to
include all this information,
because they needed to know it.
And that was really
the deciding factor
in how much information
to include.
So I have a second
example here, where I'll go
into a little more detail about
how exactly I made the design,
and how I try to think
about the audience
in concrete ways
throughout the process
of making an infographic.
This is a poster from
the same project.
It's about 60 different kinds
of viruses that affect humans,
and which you might need to know
about, that are common diseases,
or are important in
various other ways.
And the poster is arranged where
-- you probably can't read it,
but each of those little gray
boxes is one specific type
of virus, and the box contains
some kind of interesting facts
that you probably need to know.
And these specific facts include
things like, well, the symptoms
if you get the virus, how you
might be able to treat it,
and also I used some icons
to provide a little
more information
that might also be useful
for medical students,
which is my audience.
So I have a little vaccine icon
on some of these virus boxes
to show the ones where we
actually do have a vaccine
for that virus.
A lot of them don't.
And I also have an
insect icon --
actually not sure if there's
one here that shows it,
but I have an insect icon to
show which viruses can be spread
by mosquitoes, or ticks,
or other arthropods.
So I'll show you some
sketches from the process
of making this infographic,
and really the major point,
or the major problem that I
had when first starting out,
was deciding how to arrange
these 60 different types
of viruses on one diagram.
Because if you have 60
things, there are a lot
of different ways
to arrange them.
You could arrange
them by phylogeny,
like a family tree of viruses.
You could arrange
them by order of --
you know, how dangerous they
are to people, or group them
by how you would treat
the virus infection,
or into general categories
of biology.
And so when I have a kind of
open-ended question like that,
I try to think of a
couple of these solutions,
and then pick the one that
really makes the most sense
for my particular audience.
So in my case, the audience
is medical students.
They don't actually really need
to know how viruses are
related to each other.
This isn't a project meant
for evolutionary biologists,
so that's probably not
a great way to do it.
And metrics like how dangerous a
virus is, or how to treat it --
that -- those things
can really depend
on a lot of external factors.
So that's also -- I also
don't think that's a great way
to arrange something like that.
And what I ended up doing is to
divide up these 60 viruses based
on three very broad,
major groupings.
So on the bottom of the figure,
in pink here, those are all
of the viruses that
infect humans using RNA,
and in the top, those
are two different types
of viruses that use DNA.
And these are, you
know, very broad topics,
and I could've made
this a family tree.
I could've put a lot more
information here, but really,
for the purposes
of my audience --
you know, medical students
studying for an exam --
they really don't
need that information.
And it's enough to just
have these three major types
of biological -- you
know, how viruses work.
And sometimes, I think it's
actually better to have just --
you know, stop at just
enough information,
instead of including
everything you possibly could.
And in the end, I play with the
color and shapes a little bit.
But the main -- you know, the
main point of the infographic,
and the majority of the layout
that I work on is really based
on these questions that I
try to ask myself about --
does the audience actually
need this information?
Like, what is -- what do
they absolutely need to know?
Because I have to include that,
and then everything else --
like, really asking
myself, is this necessary?
And this project was a
series of 20 posters.
I'm not going to go through all
of them, but throughout the year
and a half that I spent
working on the project,
these were the consistent
questions I tried to ask myself
about what the audience
was really looking for.
And I'm not a medical
student, so this kind
of thought process was pretty
heavily reliant on, you know,
medical textbooks, other kinds
of study guides for these exams.
And I also worked with Dr. Ruben
Matthews [assumed spelling],
who commissioned the project,
and who's a medical doctor
who worked with me
throughout the process.
And I think this
research was important,
because all these posters
are meant for a very,
very specific audience with
a very specific set of needs.
Like, the people who are looking
at this are actually trying
to use it to gain
some information.
It's not a project that's
meant for fun, or --
I mean, it was fun,
but that's not --
[laughter] that's not
really what the end goal
of the project is.
So that's one very
specific type of infographic
that I've designed, but I
also work on projects meant
for the general public.
And I think that's a
very different process.
So I want to talk about an
example of a project I worked
on for a more broad audience.
So this is an infographic
I worked on with "Wired,"
[assumed spelling],
about how different kinds
of plants have evolved
to survive in California,
where there are a
lot of wildfires.
It's for the general public,
and the full infographic has
six different examples of plants
that have evolved unique
adaptations to fire.
And I picked these six
plants because each
of them are very
well-known scientifically,
and they all provide some
kind of unique example.
They all have a different
adaptation to fire.
So there's the giant
sequoia, the first one,
which has very thick,
fire-resistant bark.
And the fireweed --
very aptly named --
which grows very well after
a forest fire has swept
through a region and left this
very open, burned landscape.
They grow very well in
those disturbed areas.
And the California black oak,
which has a very
extensive root system,
and even if a fire burns
most of the top of the tree,
it can regrow from the tree
stump left behind using its
root structure.
And all of these six examples
really help illustrate a very
different aspect
of fire adaptation,
and in this infographic, I'm
limiting the number of examples
to just six instead of the 60
viruses I showed you earlier.
And that's because a general
audience is much more diverse,
and I want to go into a
lot of detail with each one
of these examples, so that I can
take a group of people that are
from very different backgrounds
and really help them understand
the science in the same way.
Okay. And when I'm curating an
infographic with fewer examples,
I try to really make sure
each one has a purpose.
So for the example I
showed you with 60 viruses,
a lot of them are very
similar to each other,
but a medical student
would probably still need
to know both of them.
For here, I didn't
want to include things
that were redundant, because
I only have six examples.
So I went through and really
tried to pick out the plants
that contributed something
unique to the infographic.
Each one tells you something
a little bit different
about fire and plants.
Okay. So I've been talking a lot
about how information editing
is a constraint, or, like,
a limitation of making
infographics,
but I think it's really
also an opportunity
to try some cool
design techniques,
and do something a
little more creative.
So I made this particular
infographic with actual paper
and fire, which was
a lot of fun,
and it's something I
wouldn't have been able to do
if this was meant for a
more specialist audience.
So because it's meant for the
general public, I didn't need
to include a lot of
-- like, you know,
very specific scientific
details.
Like the number of seeds
each flower produces,
or where exactly to find
the plant, its life cycle,
all of these things
that would be important
for a more specialist audience.
So this doesn't have to be a
plant identification guide,
which means I can
have a lot more fun
with how I present the
information, and, like,
removing things like
color, and those details.
So I set the plant
sculptures actually on fire,
and videotaped them, and
afterwards, I turned them
into an animated
loop in Photoshop.
And, you know, I
accept that using paper
and fire isn't a conventional
way to make plant illustrations,
but I wanted to do this because
I think it really emphasized,
to me, what was the
point of the graphic.
Which was really how
closely tied these plants are
to wildfire, how they really --
some of them really require fire
in order to complete their life
cycle, and how this is just
such an ingrained part of
the science for these plants.
Okay, so the end
result is something
where the visuals are a
little less conventional,
but I think it still includes
a good amount of information.
And when I design infographics
for a less specialist audience,
I need to curate the
information a little bit more,
and really boil down
the infographic
to the very important examples,
because I usually
include fewer examples.
But this information editing
isn't just a constraint
for design.
It can actually open up
possibilities for new ways
of showing information.
So to recap, when I make an
infographic, I really try
to think about the audience,
what they actually need
from the project, and to try and
meet them there with something
that provides the right
amount of information.
And to some extent, the process
of doing that, and thinking
about the audience,
really influences the
design choices I can make.
And that brings me to the
graphics half of my talk.
I talk, though, from -- I talked
about the information first,
because I don't think you
can have a good infographic
if your information is bad.
But once you have the
data, then you get to work
on the really fun project
of finding an art style
that really can be
combined with the science,
and really complement
what I'm trying to say.
And this is a very
open-ended challenge,
because design can
do a lot of things.
It can make you feel, you
know, astonished, or upset,
or it can make a
difficult topic feel easy,
or at least more interesting.
So my specific goal for each
project is always a little bit
different, but overall, for all
of my projects, I really try
to make sure I have
some specific reason
for using that design style.
So it might not always
work all the time,
but if I can have a logical
reason for using that design,
I'm pretty happy at the end.
So I want to go back to this
molecular pathway diagram
as an example, and what
really strikes me the most
about this image is
the really tiny scale
at which everything
is happening.
It's really just so complicated
and tiny that, of course,
we can't see any of this
happening with our own eyes.
So when I turned this into an
infographic, I really wanted
to highlight this kind
of impossible scale,
because that's how I really
felt about the science,
or that was what I thought
was the most awesome thing
about this project.
And this concept of extreme
size really reminds me
of old constellation
charts, like this page
from a celestial atlas.
Molecules and stars are both
just so different in size
from humans that we have a
really hard time picturing them,
and understanding them.
And even though the idea
of molecules is actually a
pretty recent development,
people have been looking at the
stars for thousands of years,
and inventing these patterns and
ways of looking at size to try
and make sense of
something that's so different
in size from ourselves.
So when I made this infographic,
I decided to illustrate all
of the chemicals kind
of in the style of stars
in a constellation,
because that's a way
of understanding size that
has been part of our history
for a really long time.
And I really like this kind
of, like, visual allegory --
I suppose you would call it --
and I try to include something
like that in a lot
of my projects,
and to pick an art
style that has something
at least thematically
to do with the science.
And what I really want to do
with these visual, you know,
design experiments is highlight
what I think of as, like,
the warm, human side of science.
I think in a lot
of media or movies,
scientists are often portrayed
as these extremely serious
people in white lab coats,
and they're running around their
very high-tech lab frantically
with a clipboard.
Probably it hasn't really
been portrayed like that
at this conference, but a
lot of movies, I think --
but I don't really think science
is about the white lab coats
and the high-tech equipment.
I think it's really about
the need to understand
where we came from,
or what we're made of,
what might happen
to us in the future.
So I don't think science
is a cold, technical field,
even though it's sometimes
portrayed like that.
I think it's a very warm
expression of human curiosity,
and I want to use art to kind
of add an element of warmth
or surprise to my
science illustrations.
So I have three examples
left in this talk,
and I want to use them to share
with you a few different
examples of how I've tried to do
that in some of my
different projects.
So this first example is a
series of virus trading cards.
I animated them using a
science software called Chimera,
which was developed
by University
of California San Francisco.
Each of these trading cards
shows you the structure
of a viral capsid, which
is the protein shell
that surrounds the
genetic material inside
of a virus, and protects it.
And I've included a couple human
diseases, like dengue and HPV,
but also in the middle
is the Chlorella virus,
which infects green
algae, because of course,
humans aren't the only
ones that get viruses.
And I decided to illustrate
all of these viruses
as trading cards, and
to me, the excitement
of finding a rare trading card
is, like, a nostalgic feeling
that a lot of people
can identify with,
even if they don't necessarily
think viruses themselves are
particularly exciting
or interesting.
And I was also inspired
a little bit
by these cigarette
trading cards.
So these cigarette cards,
which you can see on the right,
were trading cards
-- were fairly small,
and came in cigarette packs
in the 1920s and earlier.
And they were really included
for structural support
for the cigarette pack, but
they came in sets of 25 to 50,
and they would show you,
you know, trading --
like, collectible
images, like fire trucks,
or flowers, or actresses.
And I wanted to play
off this concept
of having something that's
not very good for you,
like cigarettes or viruses,
but they're still very --
you know, they have something
beautiful about them,
and they're very
highly collectible.
And I liked this
idea that viruses --
I do think they're geometrically
beautiful, and fascinating
from a biological standpoint,
even if they're not
very good for you.
So my second example is this
animated butterfly infographic.
This project was
inspired by illustrations
from 19th-century
naturalists and illustrators,
like the insect pictures on
the right, and these days,
we have photos, and 3D
scanners, and videos.
So as scientists, we don't have
to draw all of our discoveries,
but with this project,
I wanted to think
about what might a 19th-century
naturalist do if they had access
to all of this modern
art technology.
What if we didn't
have photography,
but we still had computers,
and animation, and Photoshop?
And of course, that's just a
playful thought experiment,
but it was also kind of a
way for me to remind myself
of this very long history
of natural exploration.
That people thousands of years
ago, and hundreds of years ago,
have been really interested and
excited by the natural world,
and in very much the same
way as scientists today.
And this last project I'm going
to show you is an antique-style
map of Mars, and it's one
of my favorite projects.
This isn't really
an infographic.
It's more of a map, like
cartography project,
but I'm including it here
anyway because it's a project
where I've put a lot of thought
into trying to find an art style
that really worked
together with the science.
And for this map, I -- it's a
mix of hand-drawn and digital.
I -- the kind of 3D layer
underneath is open map data
from NASA, but I also printed
out a topographic map of Mars,
and traced it in pencil
to add some kind of,
like, hand-drawn feeling.
And then I added everything
back together digitally,
and the style for
this map was inspired
by 18th-century atlases,
like this map of the world.
And I love these maps
from hundreds of years ago
because there's still so much
left to explore in the world.
So you can see, like,
all of these blank edges
where the information runs
out at the top, or the sides.
There's just still so much to
explore at this time period.
We -- Antarctica, the deep
seas, like, mountaintops,
and deserts -- there's a lot
of mystery here on the map.
And now there's, like --
of course, we have these
very detailed satellite maps
and images of Earth, so we
don't really have that kind
of mystery anymore
on our own planet.
But we still don't know
very much, comparatively,
about other planets and
moons in our solar system,
so I think today, really,
planets like Mars are kind
of the modern equivalent of
this geographic frontier,
this mysterious land that we
still have left to explore.
So in this project, I wanted to
use a very similar design style
to kind of tie together how
we have such a long history
of mapping and exploring
new places,
and tie it into what we're
currently trying to do
in exploring other planets.
And I also had a
second reason here
for using this design style.
One of my favorite things
about planetary science is
how scientists have decided
to name different
features on other planets,
like mountains and craters.
And the feature naming
really is different depending
on the planet, but for
Mars, we name craters
after famous scientists
or artists,
and for very small
craters, we name them
after tiny villages
and towns on Earth.
So to me, that was such a --
like, a really fun example
of how data isn't
impersonal or technical.
Even when we're exploring
this lifeless, barren desert
in outer space, we still
give the features names
of people we care about
from history, or the places
that are really close
to us on Earth.
So my second goal here was
to use this very hand-drawn,
personal style to try
and highlight the --
I guess the human side
of planetary exploration.
And I also made a second
map in this series.
This one's for Venus, and the
history of the exploration
of Venus is actually
very interesting,
because the majority
of spacecraft
that have landed
here were probes sent
by the Soviet Union
during the Cold War.
And the Soviet Union was
actually very successful
in exploring Venus at this
historical time period.
So for this map, I decided
to use a design style
that was a little inspired
by propaganda posters
from the Cold War era.
It uses, you know, the
big, block letters,
kind of '60s-inspired color
scheme with the red and yellow.
And here, I wanted to use art
to really emphasize the role
politics played, and the role
of government in scientific
exploration, and how we got all
of this information
in the first place.
So those were two very different
examples of how I've tried
to incorporate human values
and human history into maps
of planets where no one
has ever really even gone.
Okay. So pulling back from
all those individual projects,
I want to go back to the two
main challenges I talked about,
and that I try to
address in my design work.
So from an information side,
I think it's really important
to try and understand
the audience,
and what they really
need, and to at least try
and meet them there
with something
that provides the right amount
of information, but not so much
that it's overwhelming.
And to me, this is one
of the biggest challenges
in science communication, but
even though it's a challenge,
I think it's not
just a limitation.
It can also open possibilities
for how you can communicate
the science, and introduce new,
creative ways of
showing the data.
And from an art perspective,
I think art really can add
a sense of, you know, like,
human warmth to the science,
and to really make the story
relatable, and visceral,
and make you feel, you know,
emotions about the science.
It doesn't have to be
hard and technical,
and I really think it
helps emphasize the idea
that science is just as
creative and driven by curiosity
as things like art, or
writing and literature.
And finally, I think the most
powerful stories are the ones
where the science and the
art are really integrated,
so that if you changed
either one or the other,
it wouldn't really be
the same story anymore.
And I think there's a lot of
value in making visualizations
where the art and the science
are talking back and forth
in a conversation, instead
of being dominated
by one or the other.
And that's really my
goal and what I try
to do in my design work.
So thank you for taking the
time to listen to me today,
and thank you very much to
the Library of Congress.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.